you can't really allow yourself as a
manager just to use this survey once in
in in a year or something like that to
get to understand your
your team dynamic better it doesn't make
sense in today's atmosphere
[Music]
how are you good how are you doing
i am fantastic but first i want to hear
you're just around you said yellowstone
making your way to
oregon with a laptop on your bag in your
bag as a digital nomad for the next
couple weeks right
yeah yeah so my story is uh just for
a bit of background i relocated to the
us in last november
and i was planning to explore the u.s
and then you know covered with us and
you know everything is in lockdown and i
live in the bay area
so i'm waiting for my hairdresser you
know for
five months now so i'm like you know we
were working from home and we were
walking for so many hours and we just
decided my husband and me interested
um to pack our stuff and just go and
explore the u.s a bit so i'm now
working a lot but also had the pleasure
to to enjoy yellowstone or grandpa and
now
oregon so so how does it work do you
actually literally have your your
your laptop in your bag as you drive
around and
you know in the whenever you get you get
to stop somewhere you do the work and
then you get to travel and
see some nice views and different hikes
yeah so
usually we we choose an rb with a very
good internet
yeah it is number one you know um and
and then we we try to if we manage to
finish the day a bit early and then we
managed to to hike a bit and see
exploring the area
but if not you know only just the
weekend is amazing you get to see
uh really amazing sceneries these days
and there is no
so much people right right yeah this is
not this this
is the perfect time sharon that's
amazing so so you know i want to go back
to your journey
lawyer jolt different
so many different companies along the
way and all of a sudden i just love the
personally jolt
roy and adave are such great people and
now most recently the ceo and co-founder
of cassiopeia tech
probably the most relevant thing i've
heard in
the covet age but he didn't start this
startup during the kobe times you
started
it a while back so tell me a little bit
about what custom pairs and and the
journey that took you
to create it sure um
so my background is in product
management i
learned product teams in israeli tech in
small companies
large companies also led the product
management course at joel as you
mentioned
and it was amazing to to you know
just teach other product managers
you know about the practices and methods
so you were actually a teacher for a
course
right from one of the courses of the
offer yeah i was the creator of one of
the courses yeah it was amazing
um and um and as you mentioned
so my training is in in uh i'm a lawyer
by 20. so the whole bachelor and master
being law
and um so yeah this was in another
uh life and um when i was working as a
product manager
me and a few other friends were
gathering thinking about how we can use
technology to
improve workplace environment and we
were very passionate about that
and because of personal experience we
had
so tell me about that specifically why
why change the workplace environment now
and and what year are we talking about
so we started when i was it when i think
it was 2017 when i'm still was working
and we were working no covered yet
no coffee no not yet uh and we were
exploring about how we can use
technology to
to just empower managers to
improve workplace environment and um we
realized that
with our background and our knowledge we
can create a technology that can
uh analyze different communication
patterns so data like you sent to whom
and when
no text involved and just provide
insights about team behavior
but what bothered you about the work
what bothered you about
the way that things were happening
because you know in tech it's all about
efficiency and productivity
what was wrong with the way that things
were happening in 2017
that you had that you felt like you had
to go and and think of ways to improve
the workplace
yeah i think in 2017 um so we had
our own personal experience some of the
co-founders
experienced a close exclusion or
or aggressive behavior and um
and we felt you know with in seven 2017
also
the metoo just exploded there right on
some you use just cases in israel about
sexual harassment in the workplace that
was
also very um you know very
in in their day-to-day talk i would say
uh and this is something that really
bothers us and we thought about
how how come we were so data-driven
about everything in our life but
when it comes to you know people
experiences
in the workplace we are just about you
know some
just you know just using some kind of
as just our sense our intuition
if we we hear some rumors about it where
we're not that driven
at all so we've got how we can use our
technology
our our experience in order to help
managers to do it better
so okay so so you know what are some of
the things that you're actually using
this data for
and how does it actually work
practically i'm assuming that there were
dramatic changes from
the way that you know your your solution
was adapted in 2019 versus 2020 and
we'll get to that
but but but first take me back to 2019
we're in the workplace
you know you go to meetings you have you
you do different you do different
projects you
you send different emails where does
cassiopeia
go into this whole pipeline of work
yeah so what we do we just uh gather the
data
um from email from slacks
the chats yeah platform uh also
microsoft team
um from uh calendar
and from the video platform and we just
take the ladder as i mentioned just the
metadata so
that i like houston to whom and when um
it takes between 10 to 15 minutes
to finish the technical onboarding uh
and that's it
and then we're just ready to go sending
uh weekly email reports to managers with
the most relevant
insights for them for this week so give
me give me you know
examples of some insights that i might
be getting as a manager
if i'm leading a team of engineers or
product managers in a startup so
what what are some things that i would
be getting in my weekly summary
yeah so uh it really depends on you as a
manager so part of the onboarding
process you as a manager would be able
to customize your report
basically decide what kind of insights
are more relevant for you
and what you would like to see in your
report but there is different
insights about collaboration for example
collaboration
within your team but also between teams
if there is in drop in collaboration
between two teams you will know about it
for example about new employees
onboarding new employees these days are
is extremely challenging yeah
so a lot of insights about that so for
example if we see
new employees in certain departments um
that are less connected
compared to their teammates are less
engaged so we also will
highlight it for managers to to just for
them to be aware
that they need to provide more support
for for these employees
uh so a lot about that communication how
to optimize our communication within the
company
right um so a lot of a lot of things
that basically
every teams uh everything needs these
days
i mean it sounds to me like what you're
opening up here is this opportunity
where if i'm the ceo of a company i can
come and say
well the culture that i want to have in
my companies i want people to be
communicating very efficiently so i'm
expecting them to be
on slack and answer promptly to others
i'm expecting them to
to finish their meetings on time and not
schedule back to back you know
if if i'm setting sort of these cultural
guidelines and all of a sudden i can
come in and see
okay what's actually happening in my 1
000 person organization
what is are are people actually having
like six hour meetings a day instead of
just
you know doing deep dives maybe we have
to you know maybe we have to teach
people how to have better meetings or be
more efficient in their slack
communication
so that sounds hugely relevant but how
did you deal with with the fact that you
know a lot of the meetings
don't take place over a video or over
slack a lot of them
are let's go to the water fountain and
have it and and
you know and and speak next to the like
in like we do in school
yeah so we we're walking mostly with
teams that are working remotely so
they're all
almost all communication is online and
when we're talking to remotely there's
the reason it's it's so relevant these
days
is that when you're talking to remotely
there is what they're saying in
different ways and different variations
but they they just describe that as a
manager remote manager
you're basically working with a smaller
data set so you don't have all these
small data points you used to have
in the office you don't see how peop how
people engage with whom they drinking
coffee with
right um if they're smiling during the
day you don't have right
and so as a remote leader there is a gap
here that
that is just was created um
and what we do with cassiopeia we're
helping them to close that gap just
providing them the insights they need to
get a better sense of their team
dynamics and spot
some issues in a timely manner so um
yeah and so okay so now we've reached
2020 and the world has
uh basically turned upside down every
company that tried to remain
a social company in the office is forced
into this remote environment
i on board i was on board into hippo
insurance
as a remote employee so i never actually
met
my manager face to face even though we
often
are you know one mile away from each
other but
so i i had i i think that i had a
privilege in having sort of this
introduction into this a remote work
having been onboarded back in
mid-march right when this all started
and i got to see okay what are some of
the challenges of
of onboarding and actually i have to say
that hippo did a fantastic job with that
but
but i can i can see why why it could be
so challenging so so what
what has changed in terms of cassiopeia
over the next over the last six months
or so
since covert began yeah so as i
mentioned casipia
we were providing insights about team
behavior
and in 20 in 2019 we were focusing on
providing more insights about
non-inclusive behavior so more about
aggressive behavior and exclusion we
work with large
companies mostly in the us and uk
and when coveted two of our customers
reached out to us and told us you know
this whole remote work thing
is is really challenging for us most of
our managers
are not used to uh lead people remotely
uh what can you do to help
and this just started the cycle you know
and i
oh we'll save you the details um but
just make the long story short we
decided to use our technology cps
technology to empower remote leaders
and and yeah basically we have the
privilege
and i'm very grateful for it to to
empower so many
uh amazing leaders and managers these
days so
yeah that that's that's fantastic talk
to me a little bit about the uh the
onboarding process i'm always curious
about that so you're
you have this great platform you
basically every single
company in the world is now a relevant
customer
for your for your platform what what's
your strategy like you know you're in
march you realize that okay this is my
this is my time to put on the gas like
let's double down and get there
what do you do as the ceo to make that
happen yeah
so first of all to understand who's our
early adopters
and and we are working mostly with tech
companies
uh in the uk in the us
and we're working very closely with
usually with r d
so the vp rnd or the vp engineering the
vp report act
or the cdo why is that why why why more
of the technical side i would actually
imagine that it would be more of the
sales
side or more of the product management
part of the company
yeah so also product we have also uh
product teams
um but what the reason
uh that we are working very closely with
r d
and products is that um
usually the the what we are the kind of
insights we provide about collaboration
about communication really affect
um directly on their performance and
it's really crucial
and also there's a lot of challenges
working remotely for our indian product
teams they need to collaborate all the
time
and be synchronized so there's a lot of
value
that these teams just get from using kcp
and also it's usually and if to be
very uh direct and open about it usually
this is the kind of teams that are
also very powerful within the company so
if they want to use a tool
it's easy for them to buy it so yeah
so so part of the strategy then is to go
to this to these early adopters these
teams that have the influence within the
company go to this r d manager have them
adopt within the team
hopefully have this then spread out in
inside of the corporation
and and and that way you're actually
getting also exposed to different
segments of the of the company that
might not
be incentivized from day zero to go into
your platform right
yeah that's that's so so cool why so so
you know
three years down the line why are you
still doing this well
what's up ahead i mean what what gets
you really excited about cassiopeia
today
yeah so we we quit i quit our
my job uh two years ago to to just you
know
uh lake cpr full-time um and it's it's
basic it's basically the best ride i i i
had wow
i think you can learn so much as a
founder but also
um i think what what i can
can say is that when you're very
connected to your mission
and very passionate about what you are
doing and also doing it with amazing
people you know
there is basically it's the ideal
situation for me as a person
um so i get a chance to work with
amazing people doing amazing things
build amazing products so
yeah this is why i'm keep doing it and
where are we headed in terms of
remote work collaboration do you expect
that managers are going to have even
more tools
than what we have today and and is is
this going to
somewhat also adversely affect the
personal relationship between a manager
and their employees because i'm
imagining the more data they have
in regards to you know if my manager
knows my promptness to communicate on
slack and
whether i'm smiling or not that that
could detach a little bit from her purse
from her mission to personally get to
know me but more
base her pers her assumption of my
behavior based on the analytics that you
provide
yeah so i would say that what we see as
a trend here and i think it's
it's extremely interesting that if you
think about how
companies used to to know or understand
their
culture or identify problems in their
dynamics in in
timely manner and what we we used to do
is as companies is the beginning we we
kind of performed some kind of a survey
endless surveys i was just about to say
in the army every two minutes had a
survey to fill out
exactly so you know what i'm talking
about usually
it's it's some kind of external what's
external kind of
consultant um doing some surveys and
this was the first stage right
and then the second stage was um survey
uh software's like quarter ramp and pcon
so companies can do it in in-house right
um and both uh both stages are more
designed for hr people human resource
people
um and this was great and then the the
next stage
was using more advanced data so data
like
the network analysis things that we are
doing um more
advanced data also for software that are
designed for hr and people analytics
people
persons so you can see a very complex
dashboard with a lot of
graphs and and you need to really dig
into the data to get what you need
and now these days what we noticed
is that there's now we are getting to
the last stage
which is more uh people analytics uh
platforms that are designed for managers
so because every al almost all
communication shifted to online there is
more
power for people analytics for
technologies that use this kind of
information to get more insights
also managers are expected to be more
like
uh responsible for employees
experience as you mentioned um
and and definitely there is a need for
it because uh
the the work the work you know is so
dynamic and there are so many challenges
you can't really allow yourself as a
manager just to use this survey once in
in in a year or something like that to
get to understand your
your team dynamic better it doesn't make
sense in today's atmosphere
so this is what we are getting into some
uh people analytics solution that are
more designed for managers this is what
we do at kcpa
and the and the employees have no
problem with this right they're
installing a software that basically
allows their managers to get analytics
based on their
on base based on their behavior are is
there any
you know pushback from that or do they
just accept it
yeah so you you're touching really a
crucial point so when you're using data
and that of
you know there's a lot of power there
right there is also great responsibility
um and there's a big question about how
to use this data and what we do with
cassiopeia
we provide insights on team b
on the team level or subgroup level like
such as new employees but we won't show
for example that
you know dan is not talking that much
with with john this week
okay for example so we're not gonna show
any analytics that the manager is not
aware of about specific individuals
because we want to make sure that
people feel comfortable using that right
and i think this is again one of the
most fascinating examples that we're you
know we're seeing more and more
in the past 10 years or so that we have
the data we have the insights
we're not allowing ourselves to know
them and and these are incidents that
will make the workplace better
if somebody i you know if if if you know
the manager did know
that dan and and hilah are not speaking
to each other even though they're on the
same team
then then they could take some some some
action to help correct that
but obviously the drawbacks of having
them be adversely affected by that
knowledge
and and feeling that that's not no
longer a safe space for them to operate
that that is a big problem right before
we leave i have to ask you the most
important question and i'm going to put
you on the spot once
i need three words that you would use to
describe yourself
wow this is i think it's the most you
know difficult question and it's the
most fun one
of all of them i know i know it's so
hard okay i will try
um i think uh the first one will be a
problem solver
um i i'm really passionate about
solving problems and maybe it's it's
it's part of the reason why i'm an
entrepreneur
yeah uh so definitely this is my first
word and the
second word and i'm gonna cheat a bit
but i think it's about more
pushing the limits um everybody's
cheating on this thing this
i have to find a better game so tempting
uh but i think
it's about pushing the limits on a
personal level but also on a business
level i
i definitely feel that this is the only
way to really to to develop ourselves
and to
to get to new new places as business and
people so i for example i i pushed
myself few years ago i decided to
to run a full marathon and wow it was my
first time and this was amazing
experience so i i
i really try in my day to day i love it
which marathon was this television the
television marathon
amazing amazing i plan to do
the one in herself but it got cancelled
so
yeah i actually ended up i signed up for
the a lot marathon
of 2017 and only when i got there i
realized that i signed up to run on on
dunes instead of you know a nice road
uh it was an engine it was an
interesting experience to say the least
i'm still still doing exercises to
relieve the tension but
but it was a good experience no matter
what yeah very last thing
one advice you would give yourself you
know you didn't even talk about this
transition from being a lawyer and you
were dealing with ip stuff
to being a product manager and then as
and then an entrepreneur
it doesn't sound like the natural
transition for a lot of entrepreneurs
and a lot of product managers
what what is the piece of advice that
you would now go back to the hebrew
university where you were studying it
and gave
and give yourself shiran this is you
know my two cents from the future
wow um this one is it might even be
harder than the three words
yeah yeah yeah you're really you know
pushing my limits here
uh so i would say um
keep an open minded yeah just um
yeah there's so many amazing things and
i was sure that i'm gonna be a lawyer or
a judge and you know this
this was my you know my purpose in life
and i
discovered you know there is amazing
things other amazing things that come
they're a better fit for me so just to
keep uh
to be open-minded about you know the
opportunities
and to just keep learning i think i love
it this is you know
amazing i love it
enjoy a yellowstone enjoy oregon and and
i love what you're doing there and i
can't wait to share this with the world
thank you very much
thank you thank you for having me
you